le remercie retour sur le terrain des
grandes manoeuvres préélectorale comment
les différents partis se prépare-t-il en
vue des élections régionales de décembre
prochain
le débat est ouvert il est animé et la
voix est libre on y retourne merci à mes
noël un petit mot avant d'attaquer
effectivement les élections régionales
avec julien audy où il va puisque un
nouveau conseiller départemental vous en
avait que deux lors des dernières
élections
vous avez une démission un autre qui
veut pas siéger alors il va y avoir une
nouvelle élection
a villeneuve c'est quand même embêtant
on reçoit le conseiller soit pas resté
oui alors j'aimerais poser quelques
clarifications sur la démission de notre
candidat ça d'autres élus clodion donc
qui a agi avec beaucoup de
responsabilités beaucoup de courage
puisqu'il a il a vu qu'il ne pouvait pas
concilier son activité professionnelle
avec son mandat et il a préféré donc
j'irai pour respecter ses électeurs
rendre son mandat et c'est vrai que
c'est une attitude responsable puisqu'il
ne servait pas avant pardonnez moi mais
quand on se présente à une élection
homme est venu il a win il a été muté
muté dans l'aube et il ya énormément d
lui-même ps qui pendant six ans
finalement que engrange engrange les
indemnités mais laissez moi pas je sais
que ça vous dérange
je sais que ça vous dérange mais je le
savais je n'ai pas parlé je ne donne pas
de leçons mais ce que sinon je ne veux
pas de l'autoroute a proposé c'est que
cette caution aurait pu pendant aurait
pu pendant six ans prendre ces
indemnités et ne rien faire au
département il a préféré
il a préféré être honnête il a préféré
tron est devant ses électeurs en rendons
son mandat si une attitude responsable
qui fait honneur à la politique ensuite
donc sur l'élection donc du 5 et 12
juillet nous avons un très bon candidat
qui s'appelle monsieur dassier claude
dassier donc à villeneuve sur yonne qui
qui était cotisations certes mais donc
qui je l'espère va permettre aux
électeurs du canton de confirmer leur
vote patriotes de mars alors voilà
heureusement qu'on n'est pas en campagne
parce que vous nous auriez trouble et
l'étende des temps de parole de
publication allez les élections
régionales pour commencer il nous reste
une dizaine de minutes dans cette
émission il faut en parler quand même
puisque les choses se préparent un petit
mot quand même sur et c'est pour vous
fait il a qu'attali françois patriat
décidé de pas y retourner
ça aura presque fait douze ans de mandat
il aura été le président qui aura le
plus c était à la tête de l'as de la
bourgogne
vous regrettez qu'il y aille pas vous
êtes content que ça marie-guite dufay
pour le ps écoutez françois patriat a
décidé effectivement de ne pas se
représenter je trouve que c'est plutôt
une décision courageuse qui est plutôt
bien perçue je regarde les réseaux
sociaux et c'est en tous les cas le
président qui a été reconduit dans ses
fonctions 2010 et qui aura duré douze
ans ce qui nous a permis effectivement
de mener des actions sur sur le long
terme sur la durée en faveur notamment
du développement économique en faveur de
la formation des demandeurs d'emploi en
faveur de l'apprentissage en faveur du
développement durable est aujourd'hui
dont tactile a décidé de ne pas se
représenter de soutenir la la candidate
sortante la présidente sortante pardo
marie-guite dufay
donc nous serons aux côtés de marie
guite et de la nouvelle équipe et il
s'est engagé aussi à faire campagne à
nos côtés alors l'autre actualité en ce
moment de la campagne
je me tourne vers vous sébastien martin
c'est la difficulté à trancher
ou pas d'ailleurs entre deux candidats
deux têtes de liste pour la droite
udi françois sauvadet à la joyan des
pour l'ump tous les trois jours on
annonce une fumée blanche d'un côté il
n'y en a jamais françois xavier dugourd
qui est vice président du conseil
départemental de côte-d'or a publié une
tribune hier en disant il a appelé sa
coup de gueule en dix ans il est temps
de siffler la fin de la récré que ceux
dont c'est la responsabilité la prenne
de votre point de vue alors vous vous
souvenez plus tôt alain joyandet je
pense en tant que membre de l'ump ou
est-ce qu'il faut trancher ce qu'il faut
non moi je d'abord dans ce débat j'ai
pris un seul parti j'ai pas pris parti
ni pour alain jouen dénis pour françois
sauvadet
je prends le parti de l'union je connais
pas d'autres stratégies pour gagner on
peut pas gagner une élection comme celle
là si on n'est pas unie tout il ya eu
une série de sondages aussi drôles les
uns que les autres je veux dire qu'est
ce qui montre il montre une seule chose
c'est que si la famille politique de la
droite et du centre veut l'emporter
elle allait nécessiter d'être élu et
feint d'être unis par don dès le premier
tour ce sens sinon il
dynamique deux premiers de la situation
identique c'est 2004 avec deux listes et
bien donc
donc vous fait pour l'union pour que les
deux s'entendent écouter regarder ce
qu'on a fait à chalon si nous nous
étions pas signé avec gilles platret je
pense que je ne serai pas sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui on sait unis on a gagné
si au niveau régional on n'est pas
capable de faire la même chose alors il
n'y aura pas le résultat victorieux
semble bel et bien écoutez je suis tout
à fait prêt à les recevoir s'ils le
veulent
on peut leur montrer comment nymphéas
chalon ils viennent à chalon en les mets
autour d'une table et on attend qu'il en
sorte quelque chose il faut aussi que
sur le terrain on prenne nos
responsabilités nous à chalon les a pris
à juillan des et sauvadet de prendre les
leurs et s'il faut un lieu neutre pour
les recevoir on les reçoit dans un lieu
neutre et on est prêt à les aider à
janis que vous pensez on sait que c'est
aussi des discussions avec une d entre
nicolas sarkozy et lui dit est ce que
vous pensez de nicolas sarkozy doit trop
parce que c'est ce qui dit qu'on soit
venu du bourg il est maintenant il faut
que quelqu'un prenne une décision et
disent quelque chose
est-ce que derrière ça y'a pas le fait
que nicolas sarkozy a dû peut-être du
mal à trancher à imposer quelque chose
non je crois c'est on est dans des
discussions avec on est dans des
discussions avec nos partenaires de l'ue
dit hervé morin ce matin dans le figaro
indique qu'il est indispensable que lier
une union des républicains et de lui dit
dès les régionales et même dans la
perspective ensuite des présidentielles
qu'il ya une primaire ouverte le plus
large possible sauf que je dirais plutôt
rire lagarde le patron de l'ubs et abat
lui dirais que ces problèmes en interne
mais je trouve c'est une position sage
stéphanie modde vous avez été aux côtés
de fadila khattabi dans une campagne
vous avez été ensuite seul en 2010 vous
avez rejoint
la majorité entre les deux tours là
votre choix c'est celui de
l'indépendance on va venir tout à fait
est ce que c'est une vraie indépendance
ou est ce que c'est une indépendance qui
changera entre les deux tours c'est déjà
une volonté de réunir l'ensemble des
écologistes sur un projet commun on a
vraiment un projet society je dirais qui
est le nôtre que nous avons depuis
maintenant trente ans que nous avons
affiné
effectivement si tout le monde
écologiste environnementalistes je
revendique quand même le fait que les
verts europe écologie maintenant les
verts soient plus soit plus écologique
et plus environnementalistes que les
autres au conseil régional depuis 2004
effectivement une grande partie 1 avec
effectivement en accord et avec lavesque
nos partenaires le parti socialiste
notamment mais nous avons été vraiment à
la manoeuvre pour pour pas mal de choses
concernant l'environnement c'est bien
sûr mais pas avec eux au premier tour
c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas
complètement se fait d'avoir une
candidats nous avons un projet donc nous
avons une candidate qui est jeune qui
représente justement le renouveau
politique n'est pas élu pour le moment
elle al'avantage de très bien connaître
à la fois la franche comté pour calais
vie et de bien connaître la bourgogne
puisqu'elle a vécu longtemps dijon
d'être dans les réseaux associatifs
donc c'est si prud'hommes pour nous
c'est vraiment le renouvellement
politique ça sera son mandat unique
donc ça c'est un atout fort et puis bon
on a effectivement un projet que l'on
souhaite vraiment pouvoir décliner sur
ce premier tour sur les six mois de
campagne qui s'annonce pour pouvoir en
informer on année science on l'a déjà
dit tout à l'heure la coop 21 qui pour
nous primordial
la transition énergétique réussir ce
chanceux c'est vraiment réussir cette
adaptation la crau changement climatique
mais aussi pouvoir freiner ce changement
me faisais des savanes où l'on perd
environ nementales certains disent que
ça va fausser le jeu parce que pour moi
on va parler par ailleurs autant je suis
moi ce que je sais c'est en tout cas
c'est qu'ici niveau local régional et
même mondial on n'agit pas sur le climat
d'ici 50 ans ça sera une catastrophe
alors c'est pas effectivement c'est pas
puni qui je suis en train de dire c'est
juste il ya une prise de conscience qui
en train de se faire et que nous on
serait vraiment accéléré parce qu'on a
plus trop choix je suis en changement
climatique en termes de biodiversité
voilà donc on a les moyens maintenant il
en a les leviers en attend beaucoup de
cette conférence pour voir lever les
milliards d'euros nécessaires des pays
développés pouvoir notamment aider les
pays en voie de développement et pour
nous et effectivement on a eu quelques
thèmes de désaccord majeur en revient
pas sur l'histoire de l'aéroport qui
finalement nous a donné quand même
raison la chambre régionale des comptes
est revenu
aussi pour pour confirmer ce qu'on avait
dit c'est à dire des dépenses pas en
phase avec ce qu'on pouvait en attendre
là sur la politique du transport sur la
suppression de certains trains ter m'a
effectivement nous pour nous il ya
vraiment la nécessité de garder
effectivement même si ça coûte un tout
petit peu d'argent de garder une
desserte régionale ont maintenant
franche comté bourgogne sur l'ensemble
du territoire voilà ne pas laisser de
certains territoires à l'abandon et tout
en voilà tout temps tout en maintenant
effectivement des blacks on a déjà joué
télé sur cette campagne des régionales
en mars et sophie montel qui va qui va
mener la mairie bourgogne et affronter
le grand public l'a vu lors de la
législative partielle de montbéliard à
l'époque le manioc ses rues ses relances
des rues taux favorable puisqu'il ya une
dimension proportionnelle dans ce
scrutin
néanmoins les sondages pour l'instant
vous crédite d'une vingtaine entre 20 et
25% on va dire 27 plus d'un est ce que
est ce que vous allez grand chose à
attendre de ces élections finalement est
ce que vous pouvez
parce que on peut se douter que vous
n'irez pas forcément quand même beaucoup
beaucoup plus haut un sondage à 25,27
maintenant ça vous donnera pas en tout
cas en bourgogne franche comté ou
position centrale à ce moment là mais je
crois vous aurez des surprises devant
décembre il y aura une grande surprise
et une grande vague patriotes qui
déferlera sur toutes les régions de
france mais nous front national on n'est
pas dans la cuisine politicienne on
n'est pas dans les accords partisans
nous ne souhaitons pas à rassembler la
gauche rassemblée droite et centre nous
on souhaite rassembler concrètement tous
les bourguignons tous les francs comtois
qui souhaite redresser leur région pour
une véritable alternative permet de
l'intérieur on fermait théâtre et
d'humour
elle n'a pas toujours le cas au concert
j'apprécie votre wii 98 c'est le passé m
mais ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'enjeu de ces régionales
c'est aussi que nous sommes les seuls au
front national à défendre finalement les
territoires puisque droite et gauche ont
je dirais ont adoubé la fusion la fusion
la fusion des régions de cette techno
régions lointaines féodal coûteuse qui
finalement vont être une misère pour nos
territoires et notamment pour l'yonne
l'yonne qui va être un territoire
complètement désoeuvrés olivier vous
êtes la fusion vous est proposé à fignon
bien sûr ça vous pousse vous en parlerez
pendant la campagne vous allez faire
campagne contre l'idée de la fusion
pendant là nous allons tellement jeu ce
n'est pas une histoire de la loi mais
paris n'est pas du tout ça pour la
préservation des pratiques sociales des
territoires des identités régionales et
cette fusion parce que cette cette carte
régionale finalement qui était inspiré
par berlin qui était commandée par
bruxelles et qui a été découpée par
hollande et valls
elle va à l'encontre de tout ça ça va
être un gouffre financier ça va être
moins de services et ce avec la
concentration des développements des
richesses des emplois dans les grands
pôles urbains tels que les territoires
ruraux votre les premières victimes de
cette relégation territoriale et ce sera
le cas pour l'yonne qui sera coincé qui
sera un véritable no man's land entre
l'ile-de-france est la région de dijon
et nice mais c'est déjà le cas mais ça
va être accentuée
ça va être accentuée entre deux grandes
régions rhône alpes et ile de france et
il est important de créer un grand
espace de vie et de développement
économiques de mutualiser nos forces de
solliciter aussi vous êtes contre
l'europe mais il ya savez combien va
coûter le recul il a mobilisé savez
combien notre oeil le progrès social et
le développement économique ainsi que la
formation est donc ça passe aussi par
leurs hommes dans la région et donc
c'est de faire une grande région
dynamique une région dynamique
moi je suis pour la fusion région
dynamique pour quelques-uns n'ont pas
beaucoup mais on peut effectivement
ensuite déconcentrer les services
publics on peut déconcentrer mutualisons
nos forces
créons des grands pôles d'excellence des
plateaux techniques sur la formation des
moins de 26 3 zones reprises la roche ne
nous répondent là mais pas la belugo
également résister donc réunissons nos
forces pour inscrire cette grande région
un espace de vie qui soit dynamique
commenté la campagne aux élections
mal merci à tous les théâtres n'aurait
30 secondes c'est le moment d'arrêter
cette émission d' arrêter ce débat
merci à tous les cadres d'être venu
d'être venus débattre pour parler à la
fois de l'actualité de vos parties et
puis un petit peu aussi des élections
régionales qui vont largement nous
occuper ne manquez pas cet après midi
l'émission spéciale sur les francos
gourmande de tournus à 15h20 et puis
samedi prochain puisqu'on parle des
régionales 11h voie libre spécial
bourgogne franche comté les deux
présidents face aux questions des
bourguignons et des franc comtois sur la
fusion des régions ah bon week-end au
revoir merci